c'est une enquête ouverte après des
insultes racistes d'une soi-disante
policière regardez les images c'est
franchement rentable
mais je l'espère
semer une carie propos des logiques sont
les plus nous les [ __ ] on n'en fait
pas
vd specter de police amer et alors
restait la lanterne et arrête je n'ai
pas vu
ça se passe de commentaire vidéo a été
vue plus de 338 fois le vrai souci alors
qu'elle est là il ya des propos et
rentable oui mais ce qu'on sait oui ou
non si cette personne est un penalty non
alors c'est faux ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas du tout flics et d'ailleurs il ya
une enquête qui est ouverte sur façon
d'identité ça ne rend pas moins graves
les propos analyser les propos sont
condamnables épouvantable et
inacceptable
horrible c'est horrible et d'une
violence d'ailleurs cette femme à
traduire ces choses horribles comme ça
en passant c'est horrible alors
évidemment elle a voulu dédouaner en
disant je suis flic et c'est donc je
t'emmerde non pas du tout aller pas fiq
les filles quand même porté plainte que
ces usurpations d'identité mais bon la
retrouver on la voit très bien ils vont
la retrouver et j'espère qu'elle va
trinquer parce que dans ces cas là c'est
épouvantable franchement s'il est
condamné par la loi ah oui il est puni
par choquant oui non mais c'est grave
justement qu'elles se fassent passer
pour policière parce que dans le climat
actuel 330000 vues il ya trois cent
trente mille personnes qui vont pas
chercher à savoir si vraiment malheureux
mais ça va ternir encore l'image de la
police donc c'est très très grave outre
le fait que cette arme est atroce chez
la très grave pour l'image de là pour le
dire telle quelle elle et elle est très
content agir comme ça et elle est encore
plus con dans sa manière de dire je suis
flic
annoncé elle est vraiment violente et
c'est gratuit
c'est surtout que là ça a été filmé donc
ça vous laisse sous-entendre que en vrai
il y en a énormément les situations
comme ça parce que les gens n'ont pas
toujours leur téléphone à la main pour
filmer la manque de bol pour elle eh ben
ça a été filmé mais je pense avoir
beaucoup plus courant que ce qu'on croit
oui la critique souvent twitter pour des
meubles pour des bonnes raisons de la
force car et samia soeur c'est un vraie
relation d'affaires de l'information
injuste il faut saluer c'est l'attitude
de ces jeunes femmes créent calcul
c'est la même vachement à la région
daniel est attendu le 10 ème à gagner en
fait c'est tellement récurrents que même
l aile sayles en offusque pas plus que
ça parce que c'est leur quotidien je
pense les pauvres quand on reçoit moi
j'en reçois tout le temps tous les jours
tous les jours sur les réseaux sociaux
mais bien sûr tous les jours sur les
réseaux sociaux pas dans la route si
violent voit bien pire que ça évidemment
mais ce n'est ici un exemple vous avez
l'a pas vu dans ce
changement d'exemple le singe retourne
dans ta savane avec ta grosse bouche
vous fait
des choses à hanouna enfin j'en ai tous
les jours tout le temps mais vous voyez
là l'attitude de ces jeunes femmes en
fait limite enfin on donne ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur elle c'est une raciste c'est
une c'est une merde de sa gamme dans
lequel elle donne scala intérieure et le
jeune femme et lui disent bonne journée
et elles le prennent bien parce qu'elles
y sont habitués malheureusement m tu
portes plainte souvent ça m'est déjà
arrivé conscient c'est seulement ça ce
sera l'un des gros dossiers magali vous
avez des graves pour ça il ya des gros
dossiers du gouvernement qui va arriver
c'est de mettre un terme et moi j'étais
à l'ap lors de l'entretien que j'ai pu
avoir avec lui est ce qu'on pourra
s'asseoir pour discuter de dunes la mise
en place de quelque chose la levée la
désolation et il m'a dit oui c'est prévu
donc évidemment et là j'ai chanté en
train de là je vais recontacter cette
semaine ce que j'ai attendu le les
délais parce que voilà ça vient d'être
réélu et c'est donc je me doute que ça
doit être un peu chamboulé mais
effectivement je vais recompte je vais
les recontacter et je pense que j'aurais
certainement ce rendez vous parce que
faut le faire c'est inacceptable et moi
je reçois des messages et reçu des
messages pareil et une juive j'en ai
reçu la semaine dernière on va te brûler
machin
truc moi maintenant les affiches et je
laisse les noms pour que les gens il est
signalé et pourquoi
pas expliqué pourquoi en fait si il ya
un signalement il se passera rien mais
mais mais en cette masse un grand nombre
de remontées il ya le goal qui demande à
mes abonnés de les signaler ces gens là
donc maintenant j'ai plus aucun scrupule
à les afficher et j'en ai affiché 2 la
semaine dernière et je crois qu'on a un
des deux qui a sauté le comte a sauté
très bon c'est un problème qui va se
proposait avec twitter si les musts
voulait donner encore plus de liberté à
twitter ça va aller à l'effet que ces
salles on peut pas dire n'importe quoi
il n 9 n'a jamais dit qu'il voulait la
liberté totale il a dit dans le respect
des lois la loi interdit les un genre
c'est parfait
il est très clairement positionné libéré
liberté liberté
il l'a mis sur son compte dans le
respect des lois ou là c'est quand même
encadrée par la loi je lui dit on à la
parole alors je suis un grand fan des
leds must mais il a dit qu'il voulait
donner comme plus une plus grande
liberté d'expression sur twitter oui à
twitter mais pas dans les injures
racines en horrible comme ça c'est dans
le respect de la loi et la loi interdit
les autres car c'est l'américaine qui
parle mais moi j'adore et les neuf mais
sur ce coup-là il aime ça
sachez qu'il ya un groupe qui s'occupe
de cinq ministères de l'intérieur où
tout le monde et il s'appelle femme
m'a dit d'y aller pour mes gosses quand
j'ai eu un problème j'ai jamais eu de
réponse a favorisé me traite jamais des
menaces de mort sur marne avec des
balles c'est vrai je n'ai jamais ça
jamais eu d'abord heureusement que tu me
l'avais dit d'ailleurs ça m'a aidé on a
avancé mais j'ai jamais eu de réponse de
fond